are you okay
okay
the town of hawkins isn't exactly the
safest place to live in and some of that
danger carried into the real-life
production of stranger things these are
the scenes that were dangerous and
difficult for the actors to film
if you're little
and you're scared of stuff do not maybe
watch the season get watch it with an
adult
number one
millie bobby brown had to do a lot of
spinning for this season 3 scene during
the scene when she is in the void with
billy her character falls backwards
after escaping billy's grip it seems
like a simple stunt but the behind the
scenes execution of this scene was
dizzying millie was hooked into a rig
that spun her around and around and
around after doing the same shot
multiple times and spinning over and
over again the nauseating experience
actually made millie throw up afterwards
and how can anyone blame her that looked
more intense than any theme park ride
number two
look at hot enough 220 degrees we just
have to figure out how to get him in
here while the sauna scene in season
three was meant to show billy burning up
the actual filming of the scene had
everyone on set dealing with the heat
the director of the episode sean levy
stated that there were 100 people
present that day on a small set that was
very tight and that he got over a
hundred different angles of the scene
things got so intense during filming
that millie bobby brown actually
collapsed due to exhaustion during the
scene and that shot is in the show finn
wolfhard caught her and had no idea what
to do you can actually see him looking
off screen for help in the final cut as
he was genuinely concerned for her
safety their commitment to the scene
paid off as the raw energies showed up
on screen
number 3
the finale of season three was an
emotional rollercoaster and no scene was
more powerful than when eleven read
hopper's note to her to ensure they got
the best most raw reaction possible
millie made sure not to read the speech
beforehand she wanted to know absolutely
nothing about it she didn't even
rehearse the scene i just immediately
wanted to put a camera on me and find
the way i react and the way i reacted
was pure devastation and sadness so the
emotions were raw in that scene for sure
on top of this they also had to film the
farewell scene with everybody she said
they imagined it was the end of filming
forever and everyone started crying when
the cameras started rolling it sounds
like it was a very somber day on set
hey
[Music]
it's gonna be okay
number four
the final showdown of season three ended
in the star court mall and at one point
saw billy pinning down 11 as he was
being controlled by the mind flayer this
was a difficult scene to film both
physically and mentally millie bobby
brown noted the scene as one of the most
difficult because the two actors needed
to figure out how they were going to
play the scene with the level of
intensity they usually bring dager
montgomery was conscientious when it
came to not hurting millie during the
scene but he also wanted to bring his
usual level of intensity if you want to
know how dedicated these two actors are
to their craft they said they would run
around the mall screaming until they
cried and we both lost our voices cause
and we don't even speak in the scene but
we were just screaming at each other
sean levy described the pair as two of
our most powerful actors
number five
daker montgomery and millie bobby
brown's intensity didn't stop at that
one scene they were bringing their
intense energy to every single scene
they filmed together even if there's no
screaming in a certain scene i'd scream
between takes and so would millie we'd
scream at each other until we cried
baker described the experience of
filming with millie as a significant
mental challenge and said that they both
gave 200 into every scene they did
together montgomery was screaming so
much throughout the course of filming
that he lost his voice nearly every day
it sounds like the dynamic between dager
and millie was truly special
number six
let's keep rolling with dager
montgomery's extreme intensity on set
during the sonos scene in season three
when the kids trap billy montgomery took
his intensity to a whole new level and
may have gone a little too far in the
scene his character billy is supposed to
taunt and yell at the kids through the
door that's what was shown in the final
cut but there was a much angrier take
montgomery actually headbutted the glass
window and did so with such force that
his head actually broke through the
glass the glass was thick and not
designed to break so it was a shocking
moment to say the least and the kids
reacted with horror it was a very
dangerous moment and it was physically
exhausting as well i put everything that
i had into it but luckily montgomery
wasn't hurt still he was hoping the take
would make the final cut imagine my
disappointment when that take wasn't
used
number seven
another scene another example of daker
montgomery's commitment to giving it 200
each and every take during the shower
scene in season three montgomery was so
physically and emotionally invested that
he didn't even realize he had covered
himself in scrapes and bruises he
learned later on in the day when he took
off his makeup and prosthetics to
discover the injuries one particularly
gross memory he recounted was peeling
the skin off the top of his toes
i said are you hurt
what's going on i heard screaming his
commitment to his character is truly
impressive
number eight
yet another emotionally taxing scene
took place in season two when 11 has a
confrontation with hopper and we went
through so many different emotions we
get angry at each other we are like we
are like father and daughter it also
sounded like the whole experience was
therapeutic for the actors as brown
stated that arguing wasn't limited to
just on camera we got angry with each
other and we would express our feelings
on and off the set david harbour also
had a cathartic experience filming these
emotionally demanding scenes it was a
sort of unlocking in me as a human being
of like a love that was uh human but
that was pure number nine
will's possession scene in season two
wasn't the most fun experience for noah
schnapp he had to wear black contacts
throughout the day of shooting which
burned his eyes and he was nervous to
have to perform the seizure part of the
scene it was really scary you kind of
just lock up and i had to prepare for
that a lot on top of this it was
actually pretty cold on set the heaters
you see didn't actually work to heat up
the room it was winter during shooting
and noah's clothing was not optimal and
the cherry on top is that noah joined
the ranks of his co-stars as someone who
lost their voice due to screaming during
a scene
number 10
when eleven closes the gate during the
season two finale there is a lot of
screaming and intensity it was a
difficult scene for millie bobby brown
to get through as it required her to be
lifted into the air on a crane while
yelling non-stop in between takes millie
would have to recompose herself because
the scene made her nauseous i'd have to
like take a breather throw up a little
then come back inside
do it again luckily for her the ever
lovely david harbour was right there by
her side to help out even offering her
bracelets that supposedly would help her
nausea
number 11
entering the void isn't as easy as 11
makes it look millie bobby brown was
actually floating in a pool filled with
salt for this scene in season 1. it
actually seems pretty peaceful but it
was a different story on set it was
freezing cold the day they shot this and
millie had no help staying warm in that
pool the crew tried heating the pool but
it was to no avail as it was too shallow
to retain any of the heat fortunately
for them millie was a trooper braving
the cold to get the scene done
number 12
when 11 is in chicago with kali and
tregang cauley puts the image of papa
into her mind and 11 is confronted by
him this was another very emotionally
draining scene from millie she got so
into it that even after cut was called
the emotions of the scene were still
running through her after filming was
done she went into the bathroom and
cried for about 45 minutes
number 13. a first kiss for anyone is
nerve wracking let alone having to do it
in front of cameras and an audience
sadie sink and caleb mclaughlin both had
their first kiss during the school dance
scene at the end of season 2. sadie was
actually told about the kissing scene
the day before it was going to happen as
it was never in the script the duffer
brothers revealed they were initially
joking when they told her but decided to
do the kiss for real when they saw how
strongly sadie reacted to make things a
thousand times worse there were a ton of
people watching just to guarantee
maximum awkwardness my first kiss was in
front of like two women
and their parents and the crew and my
mom number 14.
sadie and caleb weren't the only two
that kissed that day right before they
did their kissing scene finn wolfhard
and millie bobby brown shared a kiss of
their own they had already kissed in
season 1 but that didn't stop this
moment from being very awkward as we
know the set was full of people watching
on top of this wolfhard stated that the
gym they were filming in was very hot to
make things even weirder all the extras
clapped after they kissed talk about
uncomfortable at least wolfhard warned
millie before going for the kiss he was
like okay i'm coming in number 15.
as we've learned millie bobby brown has
done a lot of screaming during her time
playing the character 11. however season
3 was a particularly scream-filled
season for millie she stated that she
lost her voice five times over the eight
months she was filming but just because
filming was over didn't mean the
screaming was too millie was brought
back into the recording booth to record
additional lines and dub over the ones
she already did this meant screaming all
over again i was screaming so much
during the shoot
usually
but she doesn't like this voice
it sure does sound like filming for
stranger things was an intense
experience did you know millie bobby
brown tore her kneecap while filming for
stranger things season 3 was still
ongoing it didn't happen on set but did
affect the production she ended up
needing a stunt double to fill in for a
lot of her scenes let us know your
thoughts about these dangerous scenes in
the comments and thanks for stopping by
at the things